hello I'm Simon official i am a member
of the disaster management Global Agenda
Council here at the World Economic Forum
over the last two days the group i'm
involved with us had very interesting
discussions on a new business model in
relation to community resilience what do
we mean by that we mean the measures
necessary to strengthen a community's
ability to cope with and recover from a
natural disaster the new business model
that we're talking about involves a new
tripartite arrangement between
governments humanitarian sector partners
and the private sector in looking at how
we can collaborate work together to
strengthen communities resilience and
also business resilience this new
dimension around business is extremely
important as we feel it's a gap that's
been missing in the past that we focused
a lot on the human needs in relation to
a disaster and less looking at what
businesses how businesses are affected
and what businesses can do to support
their own business continuity and also
to support a community to get back on
its feet